Dragon Ball used to be a show with a lot
of blood in it due to its crazy fights
okay I gotta be that guy again okay I
don't want to be that guy but this is
kinda wrong okay so yes well
it isn't really the issue at all uh a
short glance at other toy properties
like one piece and even Dragon Ball Kai
will prove that Beyond any reasonable
doubt
um what has changed is their willingness
to accept dismemberment or realistic
holes in the bodies uh that's sort of a
step too far and the reason for that
change is actually far more boring than
you might realize the real answer is
that Dragon Ball is now an international
product and it being censored this way
just makes it much more easy to be
syndicated across the world it's just
that simple